MICHELLE WILLIAMS:
Welcome to The Forum,
live-streamed worldwide
from the Leadership Studio
at the Harvard T.H. Chan
School of Public Health.
I'm Dean Michelle Williams.
The Forum is a collaboration
between the Harvard Chan School
and independent news media.
Each program features
a panel of experts
addressing some of today's most
pressing public health issues.
The Forum is one way
the school advances
the frontiers of public
health, and makes
scientific insights accessible
to policymakers and the public.
I hope you find this program
engaging and informative.
Thank you for joining us.
CAROLINE HUMER: Welcome.
My name is Caroline Humer.
I'm a correspondent,
I work for Reuters.
And I'm your moderator today.
We're here today to
discuss US drug prices.
Why are they so high?
The US spends the most per
capita on prescription drugs
compared to other high income
countries, according to a 2017,
Commonwealth Fund report.
Companies that astronomically
hike prices on some drugs,
such as the infamous
5,000 percent
increase on the antibiotic
Daraprim in 2015,
grab headlines.
And some Americans
are still struggling
to cope with their
medical expenses.
Sometimes they skip their
prescriptions altogether,
or they ration it and take less
than the recommended dosage.
Yet US prescription
drug spending
as a share of total
national health expenditures
is in keeping with
other countries.
So what's going on and why does
it matter for public health?
To help us unpack the
complicated picture,
we've brought together
an esteemed panel.
And starting from my immediate
right, I'll introduce them.
We have Aaron Kesselheim.
He's associate professor of
medicine, Harvard Medical
School, Brigham and
Women's Hospital,
and director of the program
on Regulation, Therapeutics,
and Law.
To his right is Richard Frank.
He's professor of
Health Economics
in the Department of Health
Care Policy at Harvard Medical
School.
Next to him is Steven
Pearson, president
of the Institute for
Clinical and Economic Review.
And at the end is Leemore Dafny.
She's a professor of Business
Administration at the Harvard
Business School.
Today's event is being
presented jointly with Reuters.
And it is part of the Dr.
Lawrence H and Roberta Cohn
forums.
We're pleased to welcome
the Cohn family today.
Thank you.
We're streaming on the
websites live now on The Forum
and on Reuters.
We're also streaming on
Facebook and on Reuters TV.
The program will
include a brief Q&A.
And so you could email questions
to The Forum at Harvard--
no.
The Forum@hsph.harvard.edu.
And you can participate in
a live chat that's happening
right now on The Forum website.
So prescription drug costs have
entered the political arena.
In May, President Trump
unveiled a blueprint
meant to address
lowering drug prices.
Let's take a look
at the announcement.
DONALD TRUMP: Today,
my administration
is launching the most
sweeping action in history
to lower the price
of prescription drugs
for the American people.
We've wanted to be
doing this, we've
been working on it
right from day one.
It's been a complicated process
but not too complicated.
And today, it's happening.
We will have tougher
negotiation, more competition,
and much lower prices
at the pharmacy counter.
And it'll start to
take effect very soon.
My administration has already
taken significant steps
to get drug prices
under control.
We reformed the drug discount
program for safety net
hospitals to save
senior citizens
hundreds of millions of dollars
on drugs this year alone.
We're also increasing
competition and reducing
regulatory burdens, so drugs can
be gotten to the market quicker
and cheaper.
We're very much
eliminating the middle man,
the middle man became
very, very rich.
Right?
Whoever those middle men were,
and a lot of people never
even figured it
out, they're rich.
CAROLINE HUMER: Well,
despite this announcement,
A Politico Harvard
Chan poll this summer
showed that just
over 27% of adults
had heard or read
about the blueprint.
And among those who were
aware, about four in 10
think that it will lower prices.
And in 2018, recent reporting
shows that drug prices
are still rising.
So as we will
hear, the blueprint
is not the only plan in town.
Democratic proposals
call for giving Medicare
the power to directly negotiate
with drug manufacturers.
That would open the door
to cheaper Canadian imports
as well.
And they want to impose
fines on drug makers
for the kinds of dramatic price
hikes that have made headlines.
So let's get into it a little
bit and start with Aaron.
Can you describe the
prescription price
setting landscape in the US?
AARON KESSELHEIM: Sure.
So first of all, it's a
pleasure to be on this panel.
And thanks for inviting
me to be a part of this.
So prescription drug
costs in the United States
make up about a
$450 billion market
and take up about 20% or
so of health care dollars.
And some private
payers are indicating
that they now account
for about a quarter
of all their spending.
And prescription drug
spending in general
is driven by brand name
drug prices, which make up--
brand name drugs make up
about 10% of prescriptions,
but 72%, 75% of prescription
drug spending overall.
And the sort of
fundamental reason
why brand name prescription
drugs are so costly
is that the drugs are priced at
whatever the market will bear.
That's the sort of general
fundamental principle for drug
pricing in the United States.
And in fact, the market
bears a substantial amount.
And that's because it's a very
inefficient and ineffective
market.
And I just want to sort of
focus on a couple of reasons
why that is.
So first of all,
there is a disconnect,
a fundamental disconnect
between the physicians
that are prescribing the drug
and the patients that are then
taking and paying for the drug.
And oftentimes, physicians
don't know what drugs costs.
And then many patients have
prescription drug insurance
to cover the costs
of their products.
So they only are exposed
to a small amount
of the cost of the product.
And many patients
then also therefore
don't know necessarily what
the full costs of a drug is.
And then, of course,
when you talk
about the insurance
and the payer market
for prescription drugs, there
is a range of different payers
that we use in the United
States to pay for drugs.
There are government payers
like Medicare and Medicaid.
And we have various
laws in place
that restrict the ability
of those kinds of payers
to negotiate with
pharmaceutical manufacturers.
And then there are, of course,
private payers as well.
And they try to
negotiate individually
through systems of complex
confidential rebates
and other mechanisms, and
that is not necessarily
a very effective mechanism.
And so, you know,
fundamentally what we have--
brand name prescription drugs
are protected by patents,
they're monopoly markets, and
we don't have an effective way
of negotiating on the
other side of that in order
to provide a counterweight.
And so I think what we'll
talk about a little bit today
are some of the mechanisms that
we could use to better do that.
But the sort of
minor changes that
are mentioned and by
Trump and the blueprint
are not necessarily going to
get at that fundamental issue
until we--
And we're going to need to
take some much more substantial
steps because the outcome
of all of this inefficiency
and these high prices
is that patients
have trouble affording
the essential medications
that they need.
And so price-related
medication non-adherence,
when patients don't take the
essential medications they're
prescribed, is way too
prevalent in the United States.
It leads to worse
patient outcomes.
People with diabetes are
unable to afford the insulin
that they need.
Patients with cancer are
unable to afford the cancer
drugs that they need,
and that will help them.
And so, you know,
I think that that
presents sort of an
ethical imperative
to try to take
care of this issue.
CAROLINE HUMER: Thanks, Aaron.
It does sound complicated.
Richard, you have talked
about diagnosing the problem
of high drug prices.
What's your assessment
of what's going on?
RICHARD FRANK: Well, like
Aaron, competition actually
does a pretty good job
at harnessing the prices
when it's there.
And the question is, why
isn't it there more often?
You know, the place
that it doesn't do well
is when people are
almost completely
covered by their insurance.
They don't pay very
much out of pocket.
And where there isn't
much competition,
either due to a patent
monopoly or due to some variety
of other either regulatory
factors or market factors
that keep competitors
off the market.
And so when you have
people that are fully
insured facing a
monopoly where they
don't have a choice, an
alternative essentially,
you have a recipe
for high prices
and rapidly growing prices.
The Medicare Part
D program, which
is the place where everybody
is focused on for negotiation,
is sort of a really
interesting example of this.
It essentially
consists of two pieces.
One piece is you have specialty
pharmaceutical insurance
companies competing
to cover people.
And they in turn negotiate
with prescription drug makers
for prices.
And if they pay more
for a drug, that
comes out of their pocket, that
comes out of their bottom line.
There's a second
part to Medicare Part
D, which is what people refer
to as the reinsurance part.
And there, patients pay
about 5% of the cost.
These prescription drug plans,
these specialty insurers
pay about 15%, and the
government picks up 80%.
So are very little on the
hook for that extra cost
of the drug.
And therefore, in
those circumstances,
the incentive to fight
hard for good prices
is dramatically weakened.
And so again, what you
see is very high prices
in that section of the benefit.
And in fact, the entire
growth of the program--
well, not the entire growth.
Almost the entire growth of
the program over the last,
say, eight or nine
years, has been
due to the growth
in that reinsurance
part of the program.
Where, in fact, the competition
is most likely to break down.
And it actually turns out to
be a relatively small number
of drugs that are
generating all the costs.
In Medicare, 90% of the
prescriptions are for generics.
And generic drugs continue
to fall in price for the most
part, with some exceptions,
like the one you noted.
But there's about
probably 10, 20 drugs,
maybe 25 drugs that cost
more than $1,000 a month.
And that's where the
problem really is.
And so that has been the focus
of a lot of policy attention.
CAROLINE HUMER: Thank you.
Steven, let's dig a little bit
deeper and talk a little bit
about, you know,
brand name drugs.
How they're priced here, how
they're priced in Europe.
What's the difference
there and what's going on?
STEVEN PEARSON: Sure.
There's a big difference.
I mean, when a new drug is
approved by the FDA, not all
the time, but we often have
the chance to celebrate science
and, you know, an
achievement that
will really benefit patients.
And that does capture
a fair amount of media.
But what's interesting is
that every time that happens,
something else has occurred.
Either that day or in
and around that time.
And that's a kind of
uniquely-- in an economy,
a company gets to
name its price.
And that price is the
price that the government
will pay for what that
company has developed
without any direct negotiation.
Now, to be fair, the prices
are thought about for years
and then kind of a final phase
happens just before the launch.
And companies do
have to think about
the competitive landscape.
So you know, if they want a
certain amount of market share,
just like any other
kind of marketplace,
they have to think about
how their price will compete
given its relative
advantages for patients
versus another drug.
The reason that hasn't
led to a lot of control
on costs, certainly
compared to Europe,
is because drugs are not
easy to walk away from.
It's not like a cell phone or a
car where you can go next door
and get a different brand.
And it's essentially
the same thing.
And you can make
your own trade-offs.
Drugs really do have slightly
different characteristics.
And so, we as patients
and we as physicians,
we as health
systems, want to make
a broad variety of the
developed drugs available.
So that tilts the kind of
the dynamics of the market,
if you will, on top of
having a patent system that
at launch will give
a company, again,
a certain number of years during
which it may have the landscape
entirely to itself.
So think of name your price
as a simple overly simplistic,
but that's kind of the
way it happens in the US.
The reason that they
don't charge $10 million
is because Congress would
probably get a whiff of that
and want to have
a special hearing.
And you know, the whole system
might come crumbling down.
Europe does it differently.
And I'm using Europe very
obviously stereotypically.
But it's every other
developed country.
So you can start at the South
Pole and go to the North Pole.
Many middle and
developing countries
also have some system
of doing three things.
And like any good
slogan, it rhymes.
They aggregate the buying power.
They evaluate the clinical
and cost effectiveness.
And they negotiate.
So they aggregate,
evaluate, and negotiate.
Aggregation means that
they pool, basically
either in a national
health insurance system
or by cobbling together the
existing private market in very
specific ways, to have basically
all the weight of having all
the patients or all the
members of a country
kind of have the weight of
that in the negotiations.
So that you can say,
well, if we pick your drug
or we do make your
drug more available,
it's going to get
a lot of uptake.
Whereas if we
don't, you're really
going to hurt in this country.
So that lends to a different
dynamic in negotiation.
They evaluate the evidence.
Every other developed country
has a federal instituter agency
that takes a close look at
the comparative clinical
effectiveness of drugs at
or near the time of launch
to help inform that
process of what comes
next, which is negotiation.
And negotiation looks
very differently
in different countries.
It really does, they have
different structures.
But ultimately, the key
part about negotiation
is that these countries are
willing to stick with it.
They're willing, in
some cases, to say no.
If the price
doesn't seem to mean
that it's a reasonable value
for them and it's affordable,
they're willing
to play hardball.
And you can have some
very famous examples.
One going on right now is
around cystic fibrosis drugs
in many different
European countries.
There is a real roadblock
going on between governments
and the manufacturer.
So they aggregate,
they evaluate,
and they negotiate, and
they mean the last phase
to have teeth.
And I think that's one of
the biggest differences
that I see in how drugs
are priced in the US
versus in Europe.
CAROLINE HUMER: Thanks.
Leemore, Richard
spoke a little bit
before about how consumers
in the government programs
are protected by this structure.
You have also researched
the impact of rising drug
costs on consumers,
and surprisingly
found that many consumers
in commercial plans,
ones offered by employers
or other institutions,
may not be feeling the
hit of these higher drug
prices in the way that
we think they are.
Can you tell us more about that?
LEEMORE DAFNY: Sure, absolutely.
First of all, thank you
for having me here today.
And I'm going to echo some of
the themes that have already
been mentioned.
But a very little known fact is
that they share that consumers
are spending for
their drugs today
is actually lower than
it was over 10 years ago.
And in fact, I looked up
the statistics this morning,
national health
expenditures, and discovered
that the absolute dollar
amount that we are spending out
of pocket for retail
prescription drugs
has gone down.
OK?
So that is true in spite of the
fact that prices are going up.
And I'm not just
talking list prices,
I'm saying spending
is in fact going up.
And I believe that this
protection of sheltering
consumers, just as
Richard mentioned,
sheltering consumers
from the actual cost
of these medications
is part of what is
driving the growth in prices.
And there are various mechanisms
that pharmaceutical companies
can employ to shelter consumers.
Including co-payment coupons
for the commercially insured,
patient assistance programs
for Medicare enrollees.
And those are mechanisms
that tamp down the demand
sensitivity to prices.
Now, that's not
the only component.
Another component
is then it disables
the ability of pharmaceutical
benefit managers
to try to negotiate for
better prices in exchange
for preferred tier placement
on their formularies.
Because if I'm not paying much
out of pocket because I have
a coupon I can use,
then I don't really
care if it's a tier 4 drug.
And therefore, that
manufacturer just
wants to make sure that
the drug is on a formulary,
but is sort of indifferent
to the pressure,
doesn't have pressure
to keep the price low.
And so I'm currently
trying to do some research
to try to quantify the
effect of these programs
in driving prices up, but
I believe it's significant.
There are two other
factors that I'm
hoping to mention in addition.
One was echoed previously, which
is there are some really high
priced drugs without strong
therapeutic substitutes that
are driving high spending.
And in the past, we've
benefited from generic entry
when we were talking
about chemical compounds
bringing down the
prices of drugs.
But now these drugs are
primarily biologic compounds.
And we haven't
seen the same entry
of biosimilars in
the United States
or adoption of
biosimilars, let alone any
of the willingness to take
hard bargaining stances
as Steve Pearson has mentioned.
So that's, I think,
another key driver
of what we're seeing today.
And last, and hopefully
we'll be able to discuss it
in somewhat greater detail as
the panel continues, but there
are a fair number
of strategies that
the pharmaceutical
manufacturers employ,
which FDA commissioner Scott
Gottlieb called shenanigans.
These are attempts to
shield their products
from competition.
And also to evergreen
their products
and create new formulations,
but at the same time
avoid competition from generics.
And all of these are
really important factors
in causing higher spending,
even if consumers are not
themselves shouldering
out of pocket a greater
share of that spending.
CAROLINE HUMER: Thanks, Leemore.
We will get back to talking
about those shenanigans
for sure.
So we've heard a lot about
the drivers of drug prices.
And now we're going to
hear from a patient.
This is Pam Holt. And this video
comes from the US department
of Health and Human Services.
PAMELA HOLT: My name is Pamela
Holt. I'm a retired teacher.
I have in this last
year had to pay over
$10,000 in medical costs for
my drug to keep me alive.
I was a newly retired principal
at an elementary school
and feeling pretty
good about retirement.
Just kind of out of
the blue was diagnosed
with multiple myeloma.
I had one drug specifically
that was very costly.
Without the drug I am on, my
survival rate is much less.
I need the drug.
I thought I had a comfortable
retirement being an educator
and having social security.
But it turned out that
this drug was more than I
could handle on my income.
It became very costly
for me to the point
where just recently I
had to refinance my home.
It's impacted my life seriously.
I have eight grandchildren.
I really would like to
spoil them and take them
places and do things with them.
I can't do that.
I would love to see
action done that
would help generics
to come on the market
because that would
help me personally.
And I feel strongly that
drug companies are just
gouging patients who are dying.
VOICEOVER: American
patients first.
HHS.gov/drugpricing.
Produced by the US department
of Health and Human Services
at taxpayer expense.
CAROLINE HUMER: OK.
Well, let's talk now
about ways that we
can address these drug prices.
You know, what can be done,
what is already being done.
I think a good
place to start here
would be with that
Trump blueprint
that we referenced
at the beginning.
That was announced in July.
There's about six weeks
until the midterm elections.
And wondering if
anyone on our panel
might just address, you
know, whether or not
anything has come from that
or if we should be expecting
anything from it in the
next six weeks that could,
you know, answer
some of these issues
for people like
Pam Holt. Anyone?
AARON KESSELHEIM:
Well, so I'll start.
CAROLINE HUMER: Thanks, Aaron.
AARON KESSELHEIM:
So I think, I mean,
again, I think we
all support Pam Holt
and want to see her
do the same sorts of--
and want to have the
same kinds of goals
that she has in
trying to get drug
prices to a reasonable level.
The blueprint itself had, you
know, had a lot of ideas in it.
It had a lot of ideas at a
very sort of high, vague level.
There weren't a lot of specifics
about particular interventions.
There were a lot
of questions that
were asked where it seemed
like the government was just
trying to get information.
There were some
good ideas and then
there were some ideas that are
probably useless or bad ideas.
And so I don't necessarily
think that this
is a strategy or a
clear path forward
for trying to
address these issues.
But I do want to point out one
of the positive issues that
was mentioned in the blueprint
and that was mentioned earlier
by Leemore is the idea
of getting competition
onto the market at
a reasonable time.
And the only kind
of competition that
substantially and consistently
lowers drug prices in the US
is competition from
interchangeable generic drugs.
And so when there
are very expensive,
you know, biologic
molecules where
you don't have that same kind
of interchangeable competition,
then you can get high prices
extended out indefinitely.
And so to the extent that
the blueprint talked about it
as an aspirational
goal to try to get
more interchangeable
competition on the market,
I think that was one of
the positive ideas that
was in that document.
CAROLINE HUMER: OK.
And that competition,
it sounds, Leemore,
like you're talking about some
shenanigans that prevent that
from happening.
Maybe you could just
share that with us.
LEEMORE DAFNY: Before
I go to shenanigans,
though we love to talk about
them, with good reason,
I just want to piggyback on
something that Aaron just
mentioned, which
is the potential
to see more competition
in the biologic space.
And what actions
the administration
could possibly take
to promote that.
And he touched on this
issue of interchangeability.
And that's really the engine
of success for generic drugs
because you get a prescription
from your physician,
you go to the
pharmacy, the pharmacy
can automatically substituted
it for a generic compound
and for any manufacturer
of that compound.
The FDA has so far chosen to
reject calling biosimilars
by the same non-proprietary
name as the biologic reference
product.
And so that change in
the naming guidance
would help with this
interchangeability
that was referenced.
And the FDA also
could release guidance
on what is going to
count as interchangeable
and ideally not make
it as onerous as they
have suggested in the past.
So there are actions that could
be taken to foster greater
competition in that space.
There are also actions that
the manufacturers themselves,
the shenanigans that
we talked about,
employ in order to
maximize profits.
And one of those that has gotten
a lot of attention of late
is choosing to withhold samples
of their products from, I
should say, manufacturers
seeking to copy them.
And you can understand
competitively
why they would want to do that.
But the rationale is that
these manufacturers don't
have a proper prescription
for having this medication
and it might fall
into the wrong hands.
And then the
manufacturer might be
responsible for anybody
who's mishandled or misused
the drugs.
And there have been
many, many statements
by public officials saying
that the law was specifically
designed to enable
manufacturers to try
to copy these medications.
And the pharmaceutical
industry continues
to resist legislation
that would explicitly
require the samples to be
provided at market prices.
CAROLINE HUMER:
Just to skip back
for a second to that
interchangeability,
is there any indication
that the FDA,
that the commissioner,
Scott Gottlieb,
is leaning towards the
idea of interchangeability
in the new policies
coming this fall?
LEEMORE DAFNY: You
want to take that?
RICHARD FRANK: Do you
want me to take that?
CAROLINE HUMER: Sure.
RICHARD FRANK: OK.
This has been a debate that's
been going on since 2010
within the administration.
The Affordable Care Act,
within the Affordable Care
Act was all the authority you
need for the FDA commissioner
to, one, define
interchangeability
and set the guidance
for doing that.
Provide proprietary names,
and even more importantly,
set up a sort of rapid
process for review.
And all of those have
been very sluggish.
Moreover, on the
payment side, what
you could imagine being
done and was proposed
was to put all of these
drugs under one price,
under one code.
And so therefore, if you have
a cheap drug and a high drug,
you get a much better deal
if you go for the biosimilar,
or the generic in this case.
That hasn't happened.
And that's also not
so much an FDA problem
but the Center for Medicare
and Medicaid problem.
But all of those things
are within the authority
of the administration and
would have a dramatic effect
on competition.
CAROLINE HUMER: So to look
a little bit at competition.
One of the things that comes up
a lot, Steve, for you, I think,
is where should these drugs be
priced at in the first place.
And you know, what are
they actually worth,
what is the value of them?
Can you maybe just
talk a little bit
about the idea of an
independent evaluation
and how that might help
fix the problem in the US
with these prices?
STEVEN PEARSON: Sure.
Well, as we've all been talking
about, and as you mentioned,
this is a complex system.
So there's no one silver bullet.
No matter what you
think it might be,
it's going to have to be a
real sustained thrust with lots
of different features having
to do with competition
and other aspects as well.
So I mentioned the way that
drugs are kind of-- new brand
drugs have been priced.
It's kind of what I hope
will be viewed as old school
more rapidly than not,
because a very common way
to think about how
the price should
be aligned with the benefit to
patients is to measure that.
I mean, we get a
lot of that data
from the trials that are
used to get FDA approval.
We find out whether the drugs
extend the length of life
for patients and/or improve
their quality of life.
Sometimes that's by
having fewer side effects
or whatever it might be.
Now, you can kind
of just do a Gestalt
and say, well, it seems a little
bit better or a lot better.
But you can actually do
cost effectiveness analysis,
which really tries to measure
it in a quantified way, not
just in the short term but
really over the long term.
So we capture the real
long-term benefits
to patients and the real
long-term possibilities
that, even if it's
expensive upfront,
it might reduce hospitalizations
or doctor's visits
or other things that will
kind of balance that out.
So you wrap that
all together and you
can scale a price at how
much higher it should
be than our best current
care, if something is better,
by how much better it is.
And you scale it to the
wealth of the country.
So we would actually--
one of your questions
is, why are the price
is high in the US?
We're a very wealthy country.
For a given gain in health, we
would pay more in this country
than they would
in a poor country.
That's kind of OK.
So it doesn't bother me to see
lower prices in some countries.
It's basically their ability
to pay, their willingness
to pay, given their
other societal needs.
Well, we do have other
societal needs, too.
We have education and
defense and the environment.
So we can't spend
everything on health.
So again, you scale
up the price so
that you get a reasonable
additional cost for an added
health gain.
And that's a really
good place to start,
I think, in part because
it sends the right signals
to manufacturers.
We want you to go out and
hit a home run for patients.
We want you to
demonstrate that it really
improves their quality of
life or length of life.
We're going to handsomely
reward you if you do.
But if you come to
us with this much,
and it's smudgy
around the borders,
and you haven't
done good studies,
and we're still
in a system where
you can name your own price,
again, that should be obsolete.
The fact that you could charge
us a lot more even though it's
just like this, and we
don't have many options
to do something else.
So I'm hoping that we're moving.
And I think we are
seeing some movement, not
at the federal government
level yet necessarily,
but in the private system
and some of the state
Medicaid programs, I
think we're starting
to see some movement towards
seeing pricing as a way
to reflect the added benefit
to patients as a good anchor
from which to start.
LEEMORE DAFNY: And if I could
just summarize what you said,
the manufacturers do think a lot
about the prices that they set.
But the purchasers, they
don't think very much
about the prices
they're willing to pay.
STEVEN PEARSON: I would say
that's because, even if they,
traditionally, if they said,
I'd like to pay $100 for this,
but the company is
charging me $200,
the time they put into figuring
out that 100 wasn't worth too
much, because they're going
to have to pay 200 anyway.
LEEMORE DAFNY: Mmm.
STEVEN PEARSON: That's
part of the problem.
LEEMORE DAFNY: And
the reason they're
going to have to is they're
not willing to make trade-offs
and evaluate what's the value
added of this medication,
and this is how much
it's worth to us.
We don't see a variety of
products on the market--
an older formulation of
insulin, newer formulation
with different prices,
and then choices
for physicians and
their patients.
So the demand side
is very inelastic.
So of course, they
end up paying.
STEVEN PEARSON: That's true.
AARON KESSELHELM:
And not only that--
I think it's more
than they're not
willing to make those choices.
I think that sometimes they're
not able to make those choices.
We have laws and rules about
not excluding certain drugs
from formularies.
Various states have laws about
coverage of certain drugs.
And when you have
rules about the way
that Medicare and
Medicaid is implemented
that forces insurers to
cover all these products,
then yeah, they
could say, great, I'd
love to pay only $100,
but the manufacturer says,
well, the law says
you have to cover it,
and we have a patent so we're
the only manufacturer that's
making the product, and
so we say it's $200,
and that's what you're
going to pay us.
CAROLINE HUMER: And I think that
one drug we could talk about
along those lines is Humira.
It's the biggest drug in the US.
Their global sales
are $19 billion.
There is competition,
more or less.
There are other drugs out
there to treat the same things.
It's the biggest drug
for government spending.
And I know, Richard, that
you have looked a little bit
at the issues.
This is a drug that
the price goes up
every year in the double digits.
It hasn't stopped.
That's driven it up to--
basically, I think it's
over $10,000 now a year
for that drug.
And what are some of the
ways that the government,
as such a big spender and big
payer, can harness its power
or change the way its
buying drugs like this
to reduce the cost?
RICHARD FRANK: Yeah.
So I think, going
back to the beginning,
there are really a limited
number of drugs out there
that are really high cost, that
have little or no competition,
that you can focus on
through negotiation.
The question is,
how do you do that?
Because you have, in
a sense, two problems.
You need to have the system
set up that sort things
out when there's disagreement.
And you have to have some
protection that you're not
going to drive the price
so low that, in fact,
there won't be any
incentive for innovation,
and there won't be an ability
to make enough money to get
a reasonable return.
And so there have been
several ideas put forth.
One of them has been
binding arbitration.
And we use that for a lot
of other necessary services
in this country.
Like when police
and firemen have
a labor dispute over wages,
they're not allowed to strike.
So what you do instead is you
submit to binding arbitration.
And there are rules
that define that.
And we do it in the
most important products,
which is the NFL.
And how we sort things
out that way there.
So that would be one way.
Another way would
be to, in a sense,
have a methodology set
out along the lines
that Steve might design
to set a fallback price.
And if there isn't
agreement, then there
would be some analysis
done that would then
define a fallback price.
But that wouldn't be known until
after the negotiations failed
so that everybody
would have an incentive
to come together and
negotiate a fair price.
AARON KESSELHELM: Does
that seem possible, Steve?
Could we get to that?
STEVEN PEARSON:
Anything's possible,
depending on how challenging
the budget issues become
and how much political
pressure is focused
on any one particular area.
There's a lot going on
in Washington any day
of the week or month.
But prescription
drugs are particularly
relevant because over 50% of
Americans take them every day.
And it's something that touches
our families both clinically
and their pocketbook.
The problem is also that
we all want innovation.
We all want the next
great CAR-T drug
that's going to take a
pediatric cancer patient who
was going to die in six
months and is giving them
two, three years more,
maybe it's a cure.
I mean, these are
things that don't happen
with every new drug,
but we have to make sure
that we have the
resources to handsomely
reward and incentivize
those kinds of home runs
and not squander them where
we fail to discriminate,
as I was talking about before.
So I do think--
one thing-- when you hear about
Medicare negotiation, it does
actually sound easy
on the surface,
but once you get even one layer
down, it gets really tricky.
Does that mean
that Medicare would
have one national formulary and
kick one drug out of the market
entirely to get the best
price on another one?
If so, if they've
got that much power,
why wouldn't they
have, as you said,
maybe run the risk of driving
the price down too low?
Because there's always
more money to save,
if you drive the
price down lower,
and if you're the
only game in town.
So we are uniquely American in
all good and maybe questionable
ways, but the idea of
a national formulary
is hotly debated, even
in progressive circles.
So arbitration is an
interesting alternative,
or other options in which we
try to let the free market work.
But again, I've heard about it
called baseball arbitration,
where the two
sides come together
and the ultimate arbitrator
can't split the difference.
They have to pick one
offer or the other
at the end of the day.
And that means
that everybody has
to be as reasonable as possible.
And more likely than
not, in that situation,
I think the
companies will really
refer to data on how well
their drugs help patients.
They won't make vague claims
about needing a high price
to sustain future innovation.
They'll really kind of get down
to how well their drugs really
work.
And the payers will probably
do something quite similar.
So it all depends
on the budgetary--
you know, how many
years before we go
broke in Medicare
and other ways.
But with an aging baby
boomer population,
with fantastic innovation
in the pipeline, which
is without a doubt--
the genetic science is
coming to fruition--
I think we're going
to have to figure out
some new ways forward,
because what we want
is a grand bargain.
We want a fair price, and we
want that drug to be accessible
so Pamela Holt
doesn't have to pay
$10,000 each year out of
her own pocket for it.
And we're not there yet.
So I really hope we
wake up in five years
and we've achieved, one
way or the other, some kind
of grand bargain, because
that's the way that's
going to help real patients.
CAROLINE HUMER: And
so far, those kinds
of arrangements between
payers and drug companies
have been very limited to a
few drugs where it's well known
that the drugs are working well.
So there's quite a
road ahead to that.
And in the meanwhile, it seems
that the pharma companies
are doubling down even on
their co-pay coupon policies
to try to make the drugs
more affordable for patients.
And Leemore, I just wanted
to hear a little bit more
about how those programs affect
people's price sensitivity, how
it affects this pricing,
and what could or should
change there as well.
LEEMORE DAFNY: Sure.
Well, I think that
regulators need
to give further
thought to the policies
vis-a-vis co-pay coupons
and patient assistance
programs because having the
manufacturers of medications,
who are responsible
for setting the prices,
also be the ones who
are issuing coupons
and/or making tax-deductible
donations to foundations that
then turn around
and help patients
bear their cost sharing
component of the drugs
is like having a fox
guard the henhouse.
So if these
co-payment coupons are
banned for Medicare
and Medicaid,
although they have
low co-payments,
but Medicare enrollees--
and the reason
is they're viewed as kickbacks.
They're not banned for
commercial enrollees.
And I personally was able to do
a study on one particular kind
of coupon, which are coupons
for branded molecules
when there are generic
bioequivalents available.
And unsurprisingly,
availability of the coupons
leads to increase in utilization
of the branded drugs.
It doesn't actually
increase total utilization
of the molecule or any
evidence of improved adherence.
It does increase
spending substantially.
That's just the
tip of the iceberg.
That's just when you know
there's an identical copy
of the drug available.
A bigger issue is when
there are a variety of drugs
without perfect
bioequivalents and the coupons
prevent us from really caring
how much the drug is priced.
And some of these programs will
pay all of your deductible.
And you probably
heard some stories
about how some insurers are
fighting back and saying,
you know what, if somebody
else pays your deductible,
it's not going to count--
these co-pay
accumulator programs--
it's not going to count toward
your deductible, and partly
why should a patient who takes
a drug that has a coupon not
have to foot her deductible
when another patient who
has to have expensive treatments
that don't have coupons does?
So there's a lot of--
there's inequity in that.
And just even
thinking about this,
you can imagine that
it's entirely broken.
So the one thing in
the Trump pricing plan
that kind of surprised
me was to see
mentioned that maybe
these co-pay coupons
should be permitted
for Medicare enrollees,
because that would very
likely lead to more price
inflation and higher prices.
So I'm kind of
puzzled by that one.
CAROLINE HUMER: And I guess one
of the parts of this new co-pay
back and forth between the
payer and the drug company
is the consumer in the middle.
So have you noticed that that
has increased their exposure,
if suddenly the
deductible is not
covered by the drug company?
It seems like one day,
you're not paying anything,
and the next, you are.
LEEMORE DAFNY: Right.
I mean, certainly
consumers-- it's
the coincidence
of the deductibles
and the rising
prices of drugs that
has got this topic
in the news so much,
because as I said
before, the stats
show that we aren't
spending more out of pocket,
but it's very visible
to us because we
have the deductibles.
So there is some pressure
on the manufacturers.
And if the insurers implement
these accumulator programs
where they don't allow the
manufacturers to offset
the spending, then we get
a little bit more demand
sensitivity.
But the consumers in the
middle, let me just be clear,
that isn't really the
optimal way to go.
We don't actually want
chronically ill patients
to be like Pam
Holt. We don't want
them to be any more
disadvantaged than they already
are.
So ideally, we wouldn't have
a one-size-fits-all policy.
We would have
value-based co-payments,
and we'd have patients
with chronic diseases
taking high value drugs
at very low cost to them.
CAROLINE HUMER: Great.
Thanks.
Lisa, do you have any questions?
LISA MIROWITZ: Caroline, thanks.
Yes, we have a number of
them coming in right now.
So let's start with
this one from Jacob
who's with the Special Committee
on Aging with US Senate.
Are we seeing the European
Federal Institute's agencies
you mentioned take US
prices into account
while evaluating cost
effectiveness of a new drug?
Specifically for
specialty medications,
but also in the entire space.
STEVEN PEARSON: I should
probably take that on.
No.
Basically, when you do a
cost effectiveness analysis,
you would want to take the costs
in your own health care system.
Actually, even
sometimes the drugs
would be compared to a different
kind of best standard of care
in a different country.
It can differ from
what you see in the US.
So they would not.
They're aware that our prices
are, in general, higher,
but that doesn't factor into
their own consideration.
A few countries do
kind of a crosswalk
just to make sure how
their prices ultimately
compare to a basket of
other developed countries.
To my understanding,
for a while the US
was part of that basket for
some countries like Canada.
But because our prices
have become so high,
they've tended to kick the
US out of their comparator
because they don't want
to falsely peg themselves
to a higher price.
So they tend to peg
themselves to other countries
where the pricing is more
in line with their own.
LISA MIROWITZ: Great.
Great.
Thank you.
We'll take some
from online and then
we can check the
studio audience here.
Let's see.
I guess this might be
a question for Richard.
What are your thoughts
on the six protected drug
classes in Part D?
Do you think these
should be eliminated?
RICHARD FRANK: The
answer is some.
The six protected
classes in Part D
touch on HIV drugs,
psychotropic drugs.
And the original
idea behind them
is that they were, at
that time, mostly branded,
and they were different
enough from one another
in the responses of patients
who were different enough
that you didn't know
it till they had taken
the drug, that people
were hesitant to allow
for aggressive formularies
to be applied in those areas.
The world has
changed since then.
For example, antidepressants
are now mostly generic.
So there's-- you don't need to
go one way or the other on that
one, because there's lots
of competition there now.
But to the extent
that you wanted
to try to drive things
down a little bit further,
it's probably not
necessary anymore
to have a protected class there.
For anti-psychotics, it may
be a little bit different.
And so I think when you
start getting there,
you're talking about
extraordinarily vulnerable
populations where there's a
tremendous amount of harm that
can be done from
the wrong causes.
But in principle, you'd
like to have as few of those
as you possibly could.
STEVEN PEARSON: Sometimes I
just-- if you don't mind--
if you can imagine
the analogy whereby
the government-- private
insurance and Medicare is
required.
Well, maybe pick the
Defense Department.
What if they were required to
buy Lockheed's new airplane
at the price that
the company decides,
no matter how much better it
was than the current plane
that they're flying?
I mean, you can imagine we would
just kind of furrow our brow
and say, now, why would
any government want
to pay for airplanes that way?
Now, drugs, as you said,
in vulnerable populations
are very different.
But the economics of creating
a market in which you
have to cover every single
drug and you can't, in a sense,
compete them head
to head, and you
have to accept the prices as
determined by the manufacturer,
it's a perfect storm
for the rising prices
that we tend to see in the US.
RICHARD FRANK: An
important thing now to note
is that there are
other tools available.
So for example, you can have
various utilization management
techniques-- prior
authorizations,
et cetera-- applied to those.
And so that gives the
plans a little bit
of negotiating power.
But Steve is largely
right, and it's really
a matter of how bad are the
harms that you can possibly do
from being overly restrictive.
LEEMORE DAFNY: And you really
diminish access with those--
RICHARD FRANK: Right.
That's what I meant.
LEEMORE DAFNY: --those programs.
LISA MIROWITZ: Thank you.
OK.
This is from Sanjeev
Sriram How do
we help more Americans
understand that they
are paying twice for drugs--
once when their taxpayer
dollars fund NIH-backed research
on for medications, and again
when the drug corporations
demands exorbitant prices
for those medications?
Drug corporations are
spending more on marketing
than R&D. We've had a couple
of questions about this,
so I know--
AARON KESSELHELM:
So it is the case.
And we've done a lot of research
in our group on this topic.
The key transformational
drugs that emerge in the US
and around the world
originate, in many cases,
from publicly-funded sources.
And there is a substantial
amount of taxpayer investment
not only in the basic science
and translational side,
but sometimes all the way up
into the product development
part.
And we talked about
the CAR-Ts earlier,
and those originated in
publicly-funded science
as well.
And then what happens
is ultimately,
when a product emerges
and is synthesized,
then there's a patent on it.
And the pharmaceutical
manufacturers
then control the patent.
And so they're able
to control the prices
and control much of the
revenue that then comes in.
And then the question
asker is very
true in that a substantial
amount of spending
on drugs in the
United States comes
from Medicare and Medicaid,
which are funded by government.
Those are government
dollars as well.
And so it is the case that
there is a substantial amount
of support for a great
deal of innovation,
particularly the most
important key innovation
that comes through.
and that, I think,
is something that
does need to be better
recognized and then
also potentially taken into
account as we're talking
about what a fair price is.
LISA MIROWITZ: Great.
Thank you.
Do we have any questions
from the audience?
Does anyone want
to ask a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi my
name is Naomi Sephi.
I'm a health policy student
here at the Chan School.
My question is regarding
the European market.
A lot of the
pushback that we see
from pharmaceutical
companies, as he said,
is that lowering drug prices
will stifle innovation.
Do we see that happening
in European markets?
Are we seeing these
companies drown,
or are they able to remain
sustainable and continue
innovating even when
the government is
able to negotiate prices?
STEVEN PEARSON: Views on
that are so across the board.
So you've heard, and I've heard,
passionate, eloquent, informed
arguments that we overpay only
because the Europeans underpay.
I've heard passionate, eloquent
responses from economists
that--
now, why exactly,
if they paid more,
would the companies
decide to charge us less?
Why wouldn't they keep
charging us the same price?
Isn't more profit what
they're supposed to do?
And on the other
hand, I do believe
that the ecosystem
for innovation
is unparalleled in this country.
Your ability to raise
venture capital,
to link up to the NIH science--
the best federal funding for
basic science in the world--
and to get that into the market,
into the clinical trials,
to work with academics--
if you talk to people in Europe
they salivate at what we have.
So my hope is that there isn't a
black and white ultimate answer
to this, where we can make
this kind of unlimited claim
that we need the prices as
they, or even more, to sustain
the innovation that we've
got and that any percent
off the top will instantly
cripple innovation and stifle
it.
I think there are
ways to believe
that the companies have
generally very high profit
margins.
There's a lot of risk,
and a lot of reward,
but I think we
have a very healthy
pharmaceutical industry.
And I really do believe
that many of them
feel that, ultimately,
their strategic interest is
in having some more kind of
reliable and universal system
in which the prices are
maintained and scaled
in a way that's more sustainable
for the economies in which they
live.
Because otherwise, it's a
race to the bottom or the top,
depending on how you look at it.
And so I think we
have some recognition,
even among the
manufacturing community,
that old school
pricing and old schools
ways of justifying
it just aren't
going to cut it going forward.
RICHARD FRANK: Can I
add some color to that?
So I think one really
important thing to add to this
is that a French company
like Sanofi, they
make money selling here.
It's not like they
only sell in France
and, therefore, the only
thing that's going on
is the money they make in
France to fund innovation.
They sell to the United States.
So to the extent that they
make a lot of their money here
and a lot of their
returns here, then
that affects the investment
in those companies.
But it's not because
the companies
are French or German or Swiss
per se that their innovation
prospects are different.
AARON KESSELHELM: I also think
we should think about what kind
of innovation we want.
And if their system is set up,
as Steve talked about earlier--
if the system is set up in the
United States that you can make
a lot of money
with a little bit--
basically, putting
a little bit of risk
to make a very small amount
of change to a product,
then as a for-profit
manufacturer,
that's where you're
going to invest
the lion's share of your money.
And so I think we not only
need to think about innovation
in general but we need to think
about what kind of innovation
that we want to
try to incentivize
and whether or not the system
that we have currently set up
is incentivizing the
right kind of innovation.
And unfortunately, I think,
in many cases, it's not.
STEVEN PEARSON: Caroline,
can I return to a question
that you asked earlier,
just because I--
CAROLINE HUMER: Yes.
STEVEN PEARSON: Because
I know, sometimes,
even after a full hour, it just
seems so complicated, right?
And the Trump
blueprint won't fix it,
and nothing else will
fix it by itself.
So people sometimes
can feel this sense
of just kind of hopelessness.
I want to mention briefly
two experiments going
on in the Medicaid system and
in the private market that
shows that I think people are
willing to take some risks
and experiment.
One is the State of New
York's Medicaid program.
They did pass a law that
allows them to create a target
spending cap for their drugs
within the Medicaid system
so that they can
make sure they have
enough budget for other things.
If they're exceeding
that spending,
they are now allowed to pick
out drugs that are contributing
to that excess spend
and to identify
a fair value-based price
that they will negotiate down
to to get an even deeper
discount than Medicaid
programs usually do.
And this is the first example of
a public insurer in the United
States explicitly using
cost effectiveness
to help it identify what
is a fair price linked
to the ability to
help patients, and how
do we create levers
and carrots and sticks
and things to try
to get us there.
Briefly, in the private
market-- now, this
is very controversial.
It was just announced about
four to six weeks ago.
CVS, which is obviously one
of the big pharmacy benefit
managers, it's also a large
self-insured employer.
And it decided to change
its health insurance
for all of its
employees, and there
are a couple of other
companies doing it too,
where if after they negotiate
to the best of their ability,
the drug's price for a
new drug that comes out
doesn't get down to a fair
value-based price as determined
by actually reports
from ICER, my institute,
then it won't be covered.
It's not covered.
So this sounds like a
European approach, right?
If it doesn't meet our
cost effectiveness,
it's not going to be available.
And it's an early experiment
to see what happens.
Do we get the prices
down so that they
can keep the broad
access, or do we
have drugs that are excluded?
And really, how do we
manage that kind of tension
in the US system?
So I don't mean to overly stress
that these are the right ways
to move forward, but it's a sign
that the market and the states
feel the need to move forward.
And so I think whatever does
happen at the federal level,
they may end up learning
from these experiments.
And I think we'll
see a lot of change
over the next year or two.
CAROLINE HUMER: Thanks, Steve.
That is an interesting program.
And they're grappling
with it right now,
with the new drug that
came out to treat migraine
that's quite expensive.
It doesn't meet their barrier,
so we're watching that closely.
And so I think
we'll wrap up now.
It's been a great hour
spending it with you.
Before we go, I want to
hear from everybody--
one minute or less--
your biggest concern and
greatest hope moving forward.
Let's start with Leemore.
Are you ready?
LEEMORE DAFNY: Yep, sure.
Absolutely.
Biggest concern is those
ultimately deciding
what to cover and
at what price won't
be willing to make
difficult trade-offs-- very
exciting to hear that
the State of New York
is willing to give it a stab.
We tend to be more willing
to try these things out
on our indigent populations.
I'd like to see some
more stringent activity
on the commercial side, and
what CVS is doing is promising.
Greatest hope is that
we will engage consumers
more in selection of
their health plans,
selection of
prescription drug plans,
give them the option to
select stricter formularies.
And if they do so, then I think
we'll see a market response.
STEVEN PEARSON: So I live just
outside of Washington, DC,
so I have lots of
greatest fears.
In this domain, it's that--
and this is true in
Europe, in Australia,
wherever else you go--
these issues around drug
prices and access and costs
and patient care,
they're not easy.
There's no system that
feels like, oh, this is just
a smooth process, we
have a decision making--
everybody's happy at
the end of the day.
It requires the deepest
effort of a society
to really grapple honestly with
trade-offs and with limitations
around what we can
spend and for whom.
And that's never easy.
And so my greatest fear is
that, at this particular moment
in our political discourse,
in our public discourse,
this will be really
hard for us to handle.
But my greatest hope
is actually born out
of some of our experience
with public meetings where
we've seen patient groups
really come to the table,
not just for their
piece of the pie
but seeing the bigger picture.
And people starting to talk
about this as an ongoing issue
that we as Americans need
to sort out, and hopefully
in a way that will work for
everybody, because cures
are coming.
You'll hear about them
if you haven't already,
but we're having some fantastic
drugs nearing approval
that will provide miraculous
treatments for patients
with long-term diseases like
sickle cell, hemophilia.
And if we don't
figure this out, we're
going to have a head-on train
crash between price, cost,
and access.
So we have to get these systems
and our dialogue sorted out
because we're going to have
a great problem to deal with,
which is cures for patients
that we really want to help.
RICHARD FRANK: I
guess my greatest fear
is that the politics
of Citizens United,
which is money
and politics, will
come to dominate where
we land in our solutions,
because they often
have in the past.
My greatest hope is
that we, I think,
now have started to recognize
how important competition
is if we're going to have
a market-driven system,
and that we will aggressively
sweep away the things that
get in the way of that right
now, including especially
with the biologics side.
AARON KESSELHELM: So
my greatest fear also
is that a lot of the things
that we're talking about
may require some legislative
changes, grappling
with patents, trying
to evaluate the way
that the government buys drugs.
And that is problematic
in the current--
to get sort of these
kinds of major things
done in the current
political environment,
particularly when there is an
extremely well-funded lobbying
organization on the
pharmaceutical industry
side that actively poses a
lot of these kinds of changes.
But on the other
hand, my greatest hope
is the kinds of efforts that
you see at the state level
and that come out of patients,
because there are surveys out
there that 75% of patients
think that drug prices are
a big issue.
And if we really see patients
step forward and make
their voices heard, I think
that we can actually try
to push through the gridlock.
CAROLINE HUMER: Great.
Thank you.
Thanks, Aaron, Richard, Steven,
Leemore, for joining us today.
Thank you to our audience
and to our viewers.
I'd like to encourage you
to tune into our next forum.
It is called Conflicts Over
Science and Policy at the EPA--
Where Are We Headed?
That one will be October
19 from noon to 1:00 PM,
also at forumhsph.org.
Thanks for joining us today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]